this guy's playing Starfield in a way
that I didn't even know it could be
played he has effectively turned
Starfield into way more of a stealth Sim
I mean it almost looks like dishonest
it's clearly a mix of using effective
powers of cloaking
and I think it completely silenced
pistol nobody's even noticing that
they're all dying and this makes the
combat look so much smoother
than I even knew was possible
it's like seeing a 2023 version of a
bond game or like Crisis especially this
looks like like 007. I gotta figure out
what the hell this build is shout out to
Benjamin underscore Winters for sharing
that with his audience on tick tock